autour interview gaz au parc aschbach
superstar est superbe our way si
lunettes noires pour nuits blanches
désormais you are under arrest pourra
pas dire que tu dormais pour moi ces
gars du bar de vie du nouveau jeu tous
ces sacs at il dit quoi attaquants 6
hors délai les vapes
tu te regarde dans la glace
et hier je me dis moi dis en été nous
sape être aparté the day
il ya eu but tu changerais quoi qu'est
ce que certains échangerait bien
j'ajoute que le moc est ivre et du genre
rechargeable huit coups et un billet sur
des multicoques et et non venue tu
voulais ressembler
je connais une phase de picabia qui est
moi monsieur je me déguise en homme pour
n'être rien et bellaing qui suit
insidieuse et strasbourg dans les parent
qui t'ai vu mourir comme jeunes
il m'a aussi fait des couilles
c'était pas de l'intrépidité sais de
quoi je pense que l'instabilité celle
que c'est et on change la casse tête
le courage c'est de vaincre sa peur
où elle est mon petit gars ce ballet
royal bourg tu penses que tu vas mourir
quand
quelques revues pour bientôt un
supporter mathématiques
quand je vais très
sur un coup j'espère s'envoyant en l'air
bellemare
mais sans doute plus en en envoyant un
pur et quand même ce qui joue classe
place classe et tu te souviens 47 48 et
jours que des cjd n'y avait que je sais
long tapis c'est la sts rail
j'avais les clés il était là qu'est ce
que je crois c'est pour ça j'ai tout est
noir
c'était bon marché il avait des chiens
pisteurs en acajou aurait dit je prends
un sale
le haut du rhin faire et
j'ai trahi les faits sur un lit carré un
carré de trois mètres sur trois que j'ai
fait idem j'en ai partir il ya les des
clients haut débit cas ça va marquer
leur de soufre et de du kernic et
pourquoi tu as brûlé alors fait tout à
l'âge de 30 ans des croûtes qui pour
brûler le couteau à de pinte réduire
puis je change de taux bas c'est dur de
l'expressionnisme dadaïsme surréalisme
cubisme apprécié j'ai pu écouter à
l'échangé o'connor et sa grand sérieux
maintenant être piégé 1959 si éclaré des
trente ans
je chante pour pouvoir un jeu reprend
les manettes explication tient pas pour
ta cg encore tuer j'allais devoir
attendre je prends le bas j'ai encore
une écrite et visuelle
il ya une phrase de delacroix pied très
cruel mais qui est superbe
ils ceux ci un peintre doit savoir
attraper au vol un ouvrier tombant d'un
échafaudage dans le temps qui est
attendu c'est dur mais entre ginsburg
gainsbourg égales vers toi et pas trop
ferré gainsbourg où le peintre de
l'armée j'ai bien tu perds mais soyez
clavier bacon tepa contient berre
bientôt il amusé les machines bien
encadré et il est bootable ou réagissent
les étirer ses pièces sont tirés est-ce
qu'il est doit jouer entourant fut le
rien d'où tu crois pas qu'il serait pour
toi
de rejoindre un beau en abyssinie un
crétin
ouais pour moi c'est de voir avec
picabéa parce que celui qui pollue
jésus-christ rastaquouère les goûts il
ya beaucoup puisqu'il a tiré quelques
exemplaires il ya beaucoup on est servi
par des cons d'ailleurs trop le premier
tu es un con gainsbarre et je t'emmerde
evgeny sokolov qui pense un bon bouquin
ou que ziani marin publié par souci de
soi ah mais oui mais je suis entre eux
entre de [ __ ] par ordre alphabétique
entre entre jeunes et égide a frôlé
woerth
je n'ai d
by un jour tu as dit
que je ne peux pas te réponds pas trop
con
l'homme a créé les yeux n'inverse reste
à prouver
c'est toujours assez on dire non je
crois que je viens au polythéisme à dire
je mets toujours les duos coupure est
elle de peur qui le fera nous met dans
mauvaises nouvelles des étoiles
j'ai dit dieu
yako c'est tout simple jésus était
dracénie il a dit je suis fils de dieu
est en fait
1942 tu as envie aux français d'avoir
que j'ai une étoile de shérif j'ai alors
le pas à la wehrmacht jeter les beaux
mecs qui s'est le plus passionnant j'en
veux aux miliciens au foie jaune et
prescriptions parfum ou c'est vrai que
parler hier pendant une perquisition te
cacher quelques kilomètres dans la
version de la carte d'état-major dixit
puis j'ai eu des sursis dray et ça c'est
un vécu important
coucou
lincoln
et comme petit peu con qui mènera
sûrement avril mai
qui a coulé le titanic iceberg en corps
à un juif